and finally new rule we can give up
teaching geography
grammar and math those are pretty hard
but americans
have got to learn how to take a joke
a few months ago we introduced a segment
called explaining jokes to idiots
and i'd like to bring it back tonight
for the benefit of the spike tv network
which last night
aired its guys choice awards and
censored
a joke delivered by clint eastwood but
we were able to obtain the footage of
the joke
that was too intense for america to hear
watch your monitors
dwayne the rock johnson isn't the first
athlete who's gone into acting there's
also
jim brown and caitlyn somebody
all right so we didn't get the footage
but that is exactly the line
that they cut why is caitlyn the new c
word we can't even say it in a joke
and this was on a male network that
thinks of itself as macho
but you know guys just because you have
balls doesn't mean
you have balls
so you know what is so worrisome about
this new brand of censorship
is it doesn't care if something is
actually offensive
that joke was not an insult not in any
way was it a remark that demeans
caitlyn's journey or would make her
adam's apple grow back
it's just certain words that set people
off
this is what jerry seinfeld was
complaining about last week when he said
college audiences
just want to use these words that's
racist that's sexist
that's prejudice they don't even know
what they're talking about
an opinion echoed by chris rock who said
he stopped playing colleges
because of their unwillingness to offend
anybody and larry the cable guy
concurs he said it really is a shame
that nobody can handle comedy anymore
you know when chris rock
jerry seinfeld and larry the cable guy
say you have a stick up your ass
you don't have to wait for the x-rays to
come back
that's right a black a jew and a redneck
walk onto a college campus
and they all can't wait to leave
one undergrad from san diego actually
wrote jerry
an open letter on the huffington post to
help him
jerry seinfeld better understand how
comedy works
now i sure wouldn't want to be judged by
what i wrote at 20 but
stupid though i was in 1976
i wouldn't have presumed to lecture
george carlin
on comedy though i
do i i sure wish george was around today
to write a letter back to this kid
as only he could but since he can't
allow me
dear you little [ __ ]
i'm sure you're busy with your new
letter explaining astrophysics to
stephen hawking
and giving jump shot pointers to steph
curry but
try to get a clue in the same letter
this kid cited amy schumer as a comic
who's edgy but without
indulging in harmful stereotypes okay
but what about her line i used to date
hispanic guys but now i prefer
consensual
now i love that joke because no matter
what trump says i don't think of latino
men as rapists
it's just funny because it's
exaggerating the fact that latinos
like almost all men except white guys
are more aggressive when they hit on
women
which lots of
which which lots of chicks like so
pre-fuck you on that one
see the pc police aren't saying you
can't make jokes
you just can't make them about a
protected species
jokes about men yes gay men no
kim kim kardashian's asked yes her
stepfather's tits no
if someone on the internet expresses the
wrong views about gays
women or jews they're subject to endless
shaming
unless they're muslim in which case all
that intolerance is a cultural
difference
which we just have to tolerate because
of course it's a religion of peace
there's a piece of you there there's a
piece of you there
and now let me explain why that joke is
perfectly okay
because everyone gets made fun of for
something and it's never a hundred
percent fair
if i make a and the french surrendered
joke
everyone laughs even though the french
haven't surrendered in every war
in fact mostly in just the one but it
was kind of an important one so they
have to own it
if i make a supermodel through upper
food joke everyone laughs and certainly
not all
supermodels are bulimics but more than
plumbers
if i make a joke about how all asians
are bad drivers
well that one's true
no
it's not but a little bit so we laugh as
we should when someone makes a muslims
blow [ __ ] up joke
which they have to own because they do
it more than anybody else
with the possible exception of the u.s
military